my mother and I about to lose that right  fishnet down at the beach and before it  freezes up we wanted to go get the fish  that have the eggs in them right here  will sink our dock fire pose sitting  then we'll go straight out that way  usually this time of the year we're  already fishing on top of that ice but  times are changing and have to adapt so  here we are just putting the ice net  where there is no ice  now let's see the Rope out slowly don't  get your hands cut I'm taking a bullion  here so then that will be marked so  nobody will burn it over looks like it's  that's pretty good  there's um not really any tangles one  two three go already  let's appreciate their mom that's the  kind of fish I want white fish with  exonym now we could just go and go have  white fish dinner and go check if your  dad need help tipping the sled back over  yeah